[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages time to see them what's
making the headlines with harry cole and
paper create they'll be with us from now
until just before midnight as ever
though let's start with the front pages
the metro i'm a prime minister get me
out of here headlines the metro as boris
johnson has been accused of running
scared over sleaze allegations
the eye focuses on the prime minister
refusing to apologize over the sleaze
row as he visited a hospital and missed
the house of commons debate
the guardian quotes the labour leader
stammer who accused the prime minister
boris johnson of leading the
conservative party through the sewers
and taking or trying to take down the
standards watchdog for his personal
interests
telemail leads with an exclusive on a
top conservative mp being paid hundreds
of thousands of pounds in a year for
working remotely from the caribbean the
telegraph reports that more than 11 000
people caught covet and died after being
admitted to nhs hospitals for other
reasons
the financial times leads on the uk and
u.s officials signaling that interest
rates in their countries are likely to
rise as central bankers outline
different responses to the global surge
of inflation
and the sun draws attention to behind
the scenes moments of strictly calm
dancing
or the couple rather
trying to read that one quickly didn't
quite manage it uh see if it's in your
list later later later um but uh pippa
cream and harry cole are here from the
daily mirror and the sun respectively
welcome to both of you um so pippa the
metro get me out of here uh was this uh
this boris booster uh jab um moment in
the diary or not everybody wants to know
well we actually checked out with the
hospital um thinking exactly that anna
earlier today and gave them a call just
to make sure that
the meeting had been in the diary for
some time as numbers 10 had told us and
it turns out that that was the case that
in fact
it had been cancelled and rearranged on
a couple of occasions because the pm
had uh other engagements um you could
argue that today's commons debate
on probity and standards in the house of
commons might have been another reason
to delay it so the pm could have stood
in the dispatch box and represented the
government and answered some of those
many questions that mps and all sides
had but no he decided to stick with the
plan and visit a hospital in
northumberland um obviously the
government is very keen to get back onto
probably the feels like the more
comfortable territory at the moment of
speaking about the the jobs were alright
and
the prospect of getting millions more
people jab to protect them from covid
this winter well i mean harry he doesn't
want to be tarnished or any more
tarnished with this does he but um you
do say it's the pm's chicken run for the
sleaze debate uh mocked over commons
swerve and why should he be there in
your view
because basically this is a completely
unforced own goal um if you think a week
back a week ago to when the pm quite
unexpectedly really decided to throw the
full weight of protective arm of the
government machine around a backbencher
who'd been found by not only his peers
in parliament by his own conservative
colleagues to have broken the rules
around lobbying many many times
and yet the pm you know
put the protective arm around him
wasted a huge amount of political
capital to to try and defend owen
patterson only to then pull the plug on
it 24 hours later when he realized it
was going south so i think you know
tory mps were lining up today to say
that they deserved an explanation maybe
even an apology um for for them putting
their reputations on the line defending
the indefensible now the pm could have
got to this debate there's no there's no
doubting that we went around the houses
um at our lobby briefings today on this
fact and we all remember the the hoo-ha
last week with the fact that the prime
minister last friday managed to get on a
plane and fly
um all the way from glasgow back to
london got back very quickly he has the
full disposal of the raf when he wants
it and today he decided to take the
train all the way back from northumbria
um and even then he probably could have
made the end of the debate had he wanted
to but it's obviously he's um he's left
it to his underlings to take the flat
because he desperately scrambles to move
on yeah not even the leader of the house
but the the quote that's been picked up
uh uh that's in in your story here uh
secure stamina accusing the prime
minister of leading his party through
the sewers and the stench lingers which
makes the front two of the of the
guardian um is this resonating do you
think now um pippa um you know do people
sit there and think god this is this is
back to the sort of the end of end of
major days i mean my first one of my
first jobs as a reporter at sky was
sitting in in the
in the home of one of those tory mps
who'd been accused of the brown envelope
so you know is it is it back to those
days is that is that what people are
thinking
well i think it's resonated from the off
and i'm sure harry is the same but i
spoke to tory mps last week after the
debate who were
getting dozens of emails um from their
constituents complaining about first of
all about the fact that the prime
minister was was attempting to get owen
patterson off the hook but then secondly
when he u-turned that he'd uh that's uh
you know it was it was too late and that
they had um caused chaos um
and that uh he has refused to apologize
since then
whether or not it's back to 90s levels
of sleaze i don't think we're
we're quite um at that point yet um we
haven't ended up with the you know
ministers being uh mps being being
thrown into jail yet although the
government is fighting on several fronts
it's not just obviously um they're in
paterson case there's all sorts of
questions in the papers today about mps
with second jobs which obviously
primarily affects the conservatives but
not exclusively there was the row over
the weekend about tory peerages for big
donors and the snp have asked of written
to the metropolitan police commissioner
today asking them
to investigate um and then there's a
whole sort of rise over tory contracts
over covered contracts rather
i mean they're fighting they're fighting
it off on several fronts which is why it
looks particularly currently that the pm
didn't come and face questions today as
harry said left it to his underling who
steve barkley who issued a sort of
fairly muted apology although several
tory backbenchers stood up and said you
know mark harper former chief whip
amongst them saying
you know this is a politics is a team
sport and if the captain makes a mistake
he needs to be able to
to apologize and front up for that and i
think that pressure is not going to go
away from the prime minister just
because he was
up in northumberland um it certainly
seems to be cutting through in terms of
the polls there was one poll today upsos
murray which found that his personal
ratings are slumped to the lowest levels
of personal approval ratings since he um
since he uh enters number 10 and for the
first time since the vaccine of light
the tories have pulled ahead of labour
just by one point just still in the
margin of error and it is just one poll
but it does reflect the sort of uh a
slipping in the polls for the
conservatives over the last few days so
you know i don't think this route is
over yet i think there's still plenty to
come and i think that the prime minister
hiding away rather than facing up to it
isn't going to have done many favors
yeah i mean he's been he's been uh the
teflon politician for so many years
hasn't he harry and the question i
suppose lingering for some people raised
i guess in the guardian 2 is was he
saving former minister owen patterson or
was he saving himself the guardian
pointing out that the parliamentary
commissioner for standards catherine
stone is set to rule within weeks on a
potential investigation into whether
boris johnson properly declared the
funding of this flat uh as an mp
um
you know
loaned by a tory donor to make over his
downing street flats so all of that is
rumbling plus the daily mail
when you start to see how much some mps
are making something you also touched on
in your page 2 article as well actually
not least jeffrey cox who seems to be
doing okay
yeah a great day for jeffrey cox to
announce the world thanks to a perfectly
timed update to the register of members
interests this morning uh that shows he
signed up for a new four hundred
thousand pound a year part-time job and
the mail report tomorrow that while he's
been doing a lot of his legal work
outside of parliament while parliament
said he's been doing it from the
caribbean as well so um i suspect he
will become a focal point now as the
opposition parties desperately tried to
make this row carry on we're a bit of a
repeat reprieve for downing street the
fact that recess parliament's going back
back into yet another recess this week
so mps go away from the commons there's
less opportunities to stir things up
there but crucially they'll go back to
their constituencies and we really will
find out um how much this is cut through
as as they say look obviously you've got
to look at the fact that you know the
kierstarm has been looking for an inn
as as you say to try and dent this
teflon politician for so long and he
thinks he's onto something here there
was an element but i think perhaps a
sniff of him over playing his hand a
little bit on this one he's come out
he's been locked up in isolation uh with
covert himself for 10 or so days he's
really come out and hit the ground
running but he became he's coming out
with increasingly sort of uh
increasingly louder proclamations of
corruption and do and you just want to
think hang on you know softly softly
catchy monkey here if he overplays his
hand it could have it ends up being a
bit of a bit of a shouting match that
people zone out of so we shall see time
will tell and as pippa touched on there
actually um it might be just actually a
sort of return to
sort of politics as normal at this stage
in the cycle because
the tories would have been riding higher
for the better part of a year on their
so-called vaccine bounce you know the
last time that labor were ahead in the
polls was when there was last november
when there's all sorts of questions
about why we're going to go back to the
lockdown why are we not going to lock
down then ultimately we went back into
lockdown so whether these things are
just slightly returned to normal now
we'll have to wait and see as people
said it's one pole but it's um it's
certainly keeping us busy indeed so uh
very quick look at the mac cartoon as
well um it's ironic light touch as ever
if we can see it
there we go yes uh so so matt continuing
to uh to make light of it but plenty
more to come the next part of our
program including uh that huge rescue
operation which saves an explorer
crushed by a boulder reports the daily
mail
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview uh with me now are the
daily mirrors political editor peppa
creera and the political editor of the
sun harry cole welcome back to both of
you
and harry a very important story in the
daily telegraph which is
what we always knew um
but this is obviously the latest figures
the numbers of people who caught covid
in hospital and subsequently died and
this you know really is difficult for
those families is it not what happened
to those people
yeah this is a nightmare scenario really
isn't it the reason that there is such a
backlog is people were fear feared going
in the hospital avoided doctors avoided
avoided and ease for this very reason
and this is a really good crack of the
telegraph's investigations team um so
cynic might note that they have not put
um any of the owen patterson or sleeve
stuff on the front having been
patterson's biggest defender in the
media for the last week or so but we'll
leave that aside because it is an
important story
in the fact that they've uh fawned all
the various trusts to find out
try and have a good crack at finding out
just how many people did to have that
nine months nightmare scenario of going
into hospital with something completely
different catching code and then
crucially dying and um this is a sort of
story you know retrospective stories
we'll see and i imagine we'll all form
part of a long
long looming
public inquiry into covid but um a very
good crack at the first uh first attempt
to getting in that getting that number
yes 11
688 people who died on wards after
testing positive were likely to have
caught the virus there accounting for
one in eight covert deaths in hospital
um as you say it'll it'll come out in
the public inquiry no doubt very quick
one uh front of the ft on obama pippa
yes well uh barack obama was in glasgow
today for the cop 26 summit quite
unusual on several levels first of all a
former president turning up at the
summit like this secondly the rock star
welcome that he received from the crowd
he truly is a politician who seems to
have got the public certainly in glasgow
anyway on his side he criticized one of
his predecessors donald trump and his
climate skepticism that was also unusual
really breaking convention even if it is
donald trump and uh he also overtly
criticized china and russia for not
turning up at the summit and and doing
their bits i mean it was quite striking
watching him earlier how much of um you
know what a great uh uh orator he is
compared to his immediate successors
both of them um and really all
politicians you know he's able to stand
up there and he was really punchy and
and sort of you know really speak to
people and and move them and you know i
think i think cop could do a bit more of
that from politicians right across right
across the globe if if they're trying to
inspire certainly young people he seems
to have done that yeah he always tapped
in didn't he to that let's just show you
the final story we'll talk about it uh
more a little bit later which is this
extraordinary rescue which we're now
told uh by the south of mid wales cave
rescue team uh has resulted in the
longest stretcher carry in british cave
rescue history uh the cave is stuck for
two days the mail says this uh tells us
huge rescue operation to save the
explorer who was crushed by a boulder
still not a lot of detail about that
we'll certainly try and find out more
but harry and pippa thank you both